[Music]
the undisputed highlight of the monster
verse will be published next year and
will be called
godzilla vs kong as deadline and the
hollywood reporter now report the movie
is netflix worth
200 million us dollars and of course
includes exclusive publishing rights for
the streaming service
the latest news is that warner has
turned down the offer and may be
planning to show the blockbuster
simultaneously on his own streaming
service hbo max
and in the cinema similar to wonder
woman 1984 which will be released in
december
but since three quarters of the film
belongs to the production company
legendary which in turn is a subsidiary
of the chinese wonder group
and they want to see money from it
warner could get into a quandary with
this model and despite his own
plans have to close the deal with
netflix rather complicated situation
which will certainly
also depend on the success of wonder
woman 1984.
how do you see that would you rather see
the movie exclusively on netflix
or do you simply need the cinematic
experience for the spectacular
blockbuster
write it down in the comments
you